welcome back everybody Alec Murdoch will
face hard-hitting questions surrounding
the deadly actions of his late son Paul
as the family of Mallory Beach prepares
to take him to civil court in August
nineteen-year-old Paul Murdock was
driving a boat in the middle of the
night while drunk and crashed into a
bridge at high speed Mallory B she was
also 19 was killed several other boat
passengers were injured according to
investigators Paul used his older
brother Buster's ID earlier in the night
to buy beer at Parker's kitchen which is
a convenience store beech's family is
suing the franchise itself and the
specific cashier that rung up Paul
claiming that they quote knowingly sold
alcohol to a minor Parker's Corporation
argues that the store clerk obeyed
policy by scanning a valid ID and
everyone entered the boat at their own
risk knowing that there would be
drinking this week the judge decided to
let the beach family and Parker's
Corporation depose Alec Murdock in
preparation for trial no date has been
set for the deposition as of Wednesday
but the Alec Murdoch Saga you know it
doesn't end there because a Federal
grand jury returned earned a 22 count
indictment on Wednesday stemming from
the disgraced attorney's string of
alleged Financial crimes according to
her release from the South Carolina
attorney's office Federal prosecutors
are focusing on three specific Financial
schemes in the first scheme which
allegedly took place between 2005 and
2012. they accused Murdoch of routing
settlement money from his clients into
his own pocket in the second scheme
between 2011 and 2021 they accused
Murdoch of conspiring with his Banker
Russell Lafitte to commit wire fraud and
bank fraud against numerous personal
injury clients and in the third scheme
they accused Murdoch of creating a bank
account in 2015 for the sole purpose of
funneling stolen settlement money from
his clients
Murdoch's defense team released a
statement saying in part quote Alec has
been cooperating with the United States
attorney's office and federal agencies
in their investigation of a broad range
of activities we anticipate that the
charges brought today will be quickly
resolved without a trial
it's Terry Murdoch is going to be
imprisoned for the rest of his life
assuming his appeal is denied why are
the financial crimes even being
prosecuted well it's important that they
be prosecuted first of all you want to
make sure that those victims get
restitution when you are convicted you
not only go to jail you could also have
to pay money so obviously he'll have to
figure out where that money is going to
come from but it will go to those
victims so I do think that's important I
do think that's one of the reasons that
the doj is bringing these charges now
the other thing is it could deter others
from being so greedy as we know Murdoch
was with these Financial crimes
obviously if he's convicted of it but I
do think the doj is also not focusing on
whether or not that appeal is going to
be granted because if that appeal is won
by Murdoch he gets out of jail so the
feds are going to come back and say look
we're going to prosecute you right now
regardless of what happens with the
appeal because we know Justice needs to
be done we know restitution has to be
made to those victims Brian when it
comes to the deposition in the wrongful
death lawsuit Kurt Murdoch refused to
testify or even plead the fifth to
protect himself so he could refuse to
testify however he'll he would likely be
compelled to least show up because he's
not necessarily living at home he's in a
jail cell so the courts would bring him
there they would force him to testify at
least inquire front to testify if there
is a situation where his testimony would
lead to something that is incriminating
then he could have plead the fifth
because the fifth stops you from
testifying or stops you from
self-incriminating when it comes to a
criminal context doesn't say you can
just not say whatever you wanted a civil
case but the repercussions of not
testifying would be contempt of court
but he's serving so many years in jail
it's almost like he's swimming the ocean
and dumping a bucket of water on him why
does he care and welcome back everybody
it is the second week of verdict watch
out Los Angeles in the second rape trial
of former That 70s Show star Danny
Masterson and outside Spectators are
starting to see a pattern the actor is
charged with raping three women at his
Hollywood Hills Home in the early 2000s
all three women were formerly part of
the Church of Scientology which
Masterson is still a member of he was
first tried on the charges last fall but
the jury could not reach a unanimous
decision after six days of deliberations
it was later revealed that more of the
jurors favored acquittal than a guilty
verdict his retrial started in April and
all three women testified about their
alleged assaults for a second time but
with additional details they mentioned
that they were unusually groggy and had
gaps in Consciousness after consuming
drinks made by Masterson Masterson's
attorney Philip Cohen argued that
drugging is not part of the charges and
there's no forensic evidence that
Shoshone to prove that it happened he
also suggested to jurors that the
victim's stories could be bolstered due
to financial motives surrounding the
case last Thursday the jury asked to
re-watch and re-read transcripts of a
2017 interview the LAPD conducted with
one of the accusers they asked an
additional question on Friday morning
but details haven't been released they
will return for a fifth day of
deliberations this Thursday Masterson
faces up to 40 years in prison if
convicted on all three counts while with
the pace of deliberations prosecutors
may have to try Masterson for a third
time if they want a conviction and while
trying someone a third time is rare it
does happen Seth tetral went on trial
three separate times for the same set of
murder charges in 2012 his wife was
found shot to death in bed in her rural
Iowa home prosecutors argued that Seth
was the only person with access to the
murder weapon and that he killed his
wife due to an affair the defense
pointed the finger at a mentally ill
neighbor and accused police of rushing
to blame the defendant despite a lack of
physical evidence well two years and
three trials later a jury convicted Seth
of all charges in 2014 and he was
sentenced to life in prison without
parole now you might be wondering how
come is it for trials to end in a jury
deadlock well let's break down some of
those statistics so some of the most
recent studies are from the early 2000s
a 2004 study from the National Institute
of Justice looked at 382 criminal trials
across the United States in cases
involving just one defendant 12 percent
resulted in a deadlock on at least one
count in cases involving multiple
defendants that statistic Rose to 27 the
national Center for state courts can his
study on more than 32 000 trials between
1996 and 1998
of those trials only sixteen hundred or
six percent resulted in a hung jury
Brian could or maybe even should
prosecutors really retry Masterson a
second time if there's a mistrial so it
could yes they do have the ability to do
that should I would say no and this is
why I say that prosecutors are obligated
ethnically speaking to only present
cases that they believe they can win I
don't see how they can make that
argument after the first trial leaned
towards uh an acquittal and the second
one they got even more to come in it's
like the UMP in a baseball game said hey
I'm going to reduce the strike zone and
make your bat wider and if they still
strike out after that that being they're
allowed to say the victims were drugged
they're allowed to say uh talk about the
Church of Scientology those are two big
wins for them that is different from the
second trial than the first if they
can't win after those additional help
then how ethically going to say can they
win this case so should they no could
they yes but hey we're still waiting to
see what happens so Terry if this trial
does end in another mistrial and the
prosecution files charges again what
rights this Masterson exactly have here
because it doesn't seem fair right well
you know a lot of people think he would
have the right against double Liberty
but that does not apply here because if
it's a mistrial the case is dismissed
without prejudice meaning you can always
bring it again and as Brian said you can
charge someone again when there's a
mistrial like that but here I think what
Masterson could try to argue is if
there's no evidence is the prosecution
abusing its Authority and they have a
code of conduct where they are not
supposed to be abusing any Authority and
so you know I think he could also have a
due process argument saying that he's
been deprived of life in Liberty under
the Fifth Amendment so I definitely
think that he has arguments he probably
won't win but he has those arguments
let's see what the jury comes back with
and then we will debate once again on
what should happen next if he's
ultimately uh there's a mistration